last ramadan we managed to raise five
hundred thousand half a million meals
for people around the globe this year
we're doing exactly the same by raising
half a million meals for people in
afghanistan yemen somalia pakistan syria
and the list goes on please donate
whether you can may allah bless you guys
oh my god
oh my god
yeah yeah yeah you didn't do that
did you
you don't download it i thought you guys
dropped
guys i'm going to tell you guys
something really personal now almost
every single ramadan for the last 10
years just on the last day of ramadan
before it was much time and ramadan was
going to finish i would fall into sidhu
oh
i promise you i'd finish the entire
quran this ramadan but i failed once
again please allow me to reach next year
i promise next year i will finish the
entire quran and almost cry and ask for
forgiveness that i couldn't complete the
quran and i could barely i barely put
any effort in trying to finish the quran
either i would start read three four
five six maximum get to 10 jus and then
give up right
until i made qurani last ramadan and
there's even people in my family who had
told them download qurani do the ramadan
challenge right and they didn't they
couldn't complete the quran a lot of
people miss out
the way that we made the structure in
the app is that you can see how many
jews you've completed you can see how
much percentage of the quran you've got
left you can see how many verses left
till the next jews if you want your life
to change it's free this ramadan we're
going to make qurani free for the entire
month of ramadan only if you visit this
link and put your email in so we can
make you free go to koranido
ramadan it's free it's free
yeah go download it right so guys make
sure you get it inshallah or you're
gonna regret going into ramadan you're
gonna reach the last few days and others
will have completed the quran and you
want to so if you want to connect to the
quran finish it in ramadan and build a
habit go to qurani dot app slash ramadan
and get your free trial
guys so if you already read lots of
quran on a must-have or another app and
you want to still use the qurani app
this is what you do come on to the app
click on the ramadan challenge and keep
skipping forward till you get to your
location right and something really cool
is going to happen it's gonna update all
the stats of what you've read already
and check this out six hundred and
fourteen thousand today so one letter is
normally ten hasn't been ramadan
multiply it by ten because all good d's
are multiplied by a minimum of ten so
you can see how much hassanath you gain
inshallah and once you're doing
challenge you have this really cool
representation of five or three teachers
so you can keep track uh all month and
also one thing that's amazing in the
ramadan challenge is this orange text at
the top can you see where it says uh
juice 5
123 versus left that is so powerful
because every time you see that you're
going to say let me go with 100 verses
left and then once you get there you can
say let me get to 75. let me get you
under 50 and you're going to keep doing
that till you get to the next just
you'll only know it when you go and
experience that up into allah so go
download the quran yap inshallah and
build the habit of quran even after
ramadan finishes tamarikam